hello this is Matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to go through and
explain how you can use git for your
software development so what are we
going to cover today so we're going to
introduce the concept of version control
that you will use within your DevOps
environment then we'll talk about the
different tools are available in a
distributed version control system we'll
highlight a product called git which is
typically used for version control today
and you'll also go through what are the
differences between git and github you
may have used github in the past or
other products like gift lamp and we'll
explain what are the differences between
git and get then services such as github
and get lab we'll break out the
architecture of what a get process looks
like I'm how do you go through and
create Forks and clones how do you have
collaborators being added into your
projects how do you go through the
process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you in get finally I'll take you through
a demo on how you can actually run get
yourself and in this instance use the
software of git against a public service
such as github alright let's talk a
little bit about version control systems
so you may have already been using a
version control system within your
environment today you may have used
tools such as Microsoft Steam foundation
services but essentially the use of a
version control system allows people to
be able to have files that are all
stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program that such as a website or an
application you would store all of your
version control software in a single
repository now what happens is that if
somebody wants to make changes to the
code they would check out all of the
code in the repository to make the
changes and then there would be an
addendum added to it so there will be
the version 1 changes that you had then
the person would then later on check out
the code and then be a version - I'm
added to that code and so you keep
adding on versions of that code the
bottom line is that
eventually you'll have people being able
to use your code and that your code will
be stored in a centralized location
however the challenge you running is
that it's very difficult for large
groups to work simultaneously within a
project the benefits of a VCS system a
version control system demonstrates that
you're able to store multiple versions
of the solution in a single repository
now let's take a step at some of the
challenges that you have with
traditional version control systems and
see how they can be addressed with
distributed version control so in a
distributed version control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed version control system
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed VCS server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed VCS environment is
get now you may remember that we
actually covered get in a previous video
and we'll reference that video for you
so we start off with our remote git
repository and people are making updates
to the copy of their code into a local
environment but local environment can be
updated manually and then periodically
pushed out to the git repository so
you're always pushing out the latest
code
that you've code changes you made into
the repository and then from the
repository you're able to pull back the
latest updates and so your get
repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get get
is a distributed version control tool
used for source code management so
github is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
client to that certain remote hub server
I get is used to track the changes of
the source code and allows large teams
to work simultaneously with each other
it supports a nonlinear development
because of thousands of parallel
branches and has the ability to handle
large projects efficiently so let's talk
a little bit about gate versus github so
gate is a software tool whereas github
is a service and I'll show you how those
two look in the moment you install the
software tor forget locally on your
system whereas github because it is a
service it's actually hosted on a
website yet is actually the software
that used to manage different versions
of source code whereas github is used to
have a copy of the local repository
stored on the service on the website
itself Gate provides command-line tools
that allow you to interact with your
files
whereas github has a graphical interface
that allows you to check in and check
out files so let me just show you the
two tools here so here I am at the get
website and this is a website you would
go to to download the latest version of
git and again git is a software package
that you install on your computer that
allows you to be able to do version
control in a peer-to-peer environment
for that peer-to-peer environment to be
successful however you need to be able
to store your files in
a server somewhere and typically a lot
of companies will use a service such as
git hub as a way to be able to store
your files so get can communicate
effectively with github there are
actually many different companies that
provide similar service to github gitlab
is another popular service but you also
find that development tools such as
Microsoft Visual Studio are also
incorporating git commands into their
tool so the latest version of visual
studio team services also provides this
same ability but github it has to be
remembered is a place where we actually
store our files and can very easily
create public and shareable is a place
where we can store our files and create
public shareable projects you can come
to github and you can do a search on
projects you can see at the moment I'm
doing a lot of work on blockchain but
you can actually search on the many
hundreds of projects in fact I think
there's something like over a hundred
thousand projects being managed on
github at the moment that number is
pretty much larger than that
and so if you are working on a project I
would certainly encourage you to start I
get hard to see if somebody's already
maybe done a prototype that they're
sharing or they have an open-source
project that they want to share that's
already available in github certainly if
you're doing anything with them Asha
you'll find that there are thousands
45,000 Asha projects currently being
worked on interestingly enough github
was recently acquired by Microsoft and
Microsoft is fully embracing open source
technologies so that's essentially the
difference between get and github one is
a piece of software and that's get and
one is a service that supports the
ability of using the software and that's
github so let's dig deeper into the
actual gate architecture itself so the
working directory is the folder where
you are currently working on your git
project and we'll do a demo later on
where you can actually see how we can
actually simulate each of these steps so
you start off with your working
directory where you store your files and
then you
add your files to a staging area where
you are getting ready to commit your
files back to the main branch on your
git project you want to put out all your
changes to a local repository after you
made your changes and these will commit
those files and get them ready for
synchronization with the service and
will then push your services out to the
remote repository an example of a remote
repository would be github later when
you want to update your code before you
write any more code you would pull the
latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you do
lots of really creative things that
ensure that that aid the code remains a
very high quality and B that you're able
to seam C add in new features without
breaking the core code so let's step
through some of the concepts that we
have available and get so let's talk
about forking and cloning and kit so
both of these terms are quite old terms
when it comes to development but forking
is certainly a term that goes way way
way back long before we had distributed
CVS systems such as ones that were using
with get to fork a piece of software is
a particularly open source project you
would take the project and create a copy
of that project and but then you'd then
associate a new team and new people
around that project so it becomes a
separate project in entirety a clone and
this is important when it comes to
working with git a client is identical
with the same teens and same structuring
as the main project itself so when you
download the code you're downloading
exact copy of that code with all the
same security and access rights as the
main code and then you can then check
that code back in and potentially your
code because it is identical
could potentially become the mainline
code are in the future now that
typically doesn't happen your changes
are the ones that merge into the main
branch but also but you do have that
potential where your code could become
the main code with gates you can also
add collaborators that can work on the
project which is essential for projects
where a particular where you have large
teams this works really well when you
have product teams where the teams
themselves are self empowered you can do
what a concept was called branching in
git and so say for instance you are
working on a new feature that new
feature and the main version of the
project have to still work
simultaneously so what you can do is you
can create a branch of your code so you
can actually work on the new feature
whereas the rest of the team continue to
work on the main branch of the project
itself and then later you can merge the
two together pull from remote is the
concept of being able to pull and
services software the team is working on
from a remote server and get rebates is
the concept of being able to take a
project and re-establish a new start
from the project so you may be working
approach where there have been many
branches and the team has been working
for quite some time on different areas
and maybe you kind of losing control of
what the true main branch is you may
choose to rebase your project and what
that means though is that anybody is
working on a separate branch will not be
able to branch their code back into the
mainline branch so go through the
process of a git rebase essentially
allows you to create a new start for
where you're working on your project so
let's go through Forks and clones so you
want to go through the process so you
want to go ahead and fork the code that
you're working on so this user scenario
that one of your team wants to go ahead
and add a new change to the project the
team member may say yeah go ahead and
you know create a separate fork of the
actual project so what does that look
like so when you like to go ahead and
create a fork of the repository you get
to go and you can take the version of
the mainline branch but then you take it
completely offline into a local
PAH story for you to be able to work
from and you can take the mainline coat
and you can then work on a local version
of the code separate from the mainland
branch is now a separate fork
collaborators is the ability to have
team members working on a project
together so if you know someone is
working on a piece of code and they see
some errors in the code that you've
created none of us are perfect at
writing code I know I've suddenly made
errors in my code it's great have other
team members that have your back and can
come in and check and see what they can
do to improve the code so to do that you
have to then add them as a collaborator
now you do that and get help you can
give them permission within github
itself it's really easy to super visual
interface that allows you to do the work
quickly and easily and depending on the
type of permissions you want to give
them sometimes it can be very limited
permissions it may be just to be able to
read the files sometimes it's being able
to go in and make all the changes you
can go through all the different
permission settings on github to
actually see what you can do but you'll
be able to make changes so people can
actually have access to your repository
and then you as a team can then start
working together on the same code let's
step through branching and git so
suppose you're working on an application
but you want to add in a new feature and
this is very typical within a DevOps
environment so to do that you can create
a new branch and build a new feature on
that branch so here you have your main
application on what's known as the
master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then divert your feature and then merge
it back into the master branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have here on the screen show
various different commits that have been
made so we can keep track of the master
branch and then the branches that have
come off which have the new features and
there can be many branches and get so
get keeps you the new features you're
working on in separate branches until
you're ready to merge
back in with the main branch so let's
talk a little bit about that merge
process so you're starting with the
master branch which is the blue line
here and then here we have a separate
parallel branch which has the new
features so if we're to look at this
process the base commit of feature B is
the branch F is what's going to merge
back into the master branch and it has
to be said there can be so many
divergent branches but eventually you
want to have everything merge back into
the master branch let's step through git
rebase
so again we have a summer situation
where we have a branch that's being
brought to parallel to the master branch
and we want to do a get rebase so we're
at stage C and what we've decided is
that we want to reset the project so
that everything from here on out with
along the master branch is the standard
product however this means that any work
that's been done in parallel as a
separate branch will be adding in new
features along this new rebased
environment now the benefit you have by
going through the rebase process is that
you're reducing the amount of storage
space that's required for when you have
so many branches it's a great way to
just reduce the your total footprint for
your entire project so git rebase is the
process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase it you unplug a branch and re
plug it in on the tip of another branch
and usually you do that on the master
branch and that will then become the new
master branch
the goal of rebasing is to take all the
commits from a feature branch and put it
together in a single master branch it
makes it the project itself much easier
to manage let's talk a little bit about
pull from remote so first our two
developers working together on
application the concept of having a
remote repository allows the code to the
two developers will be actually them
checking in their code into a remote
repository that becomes a centralized
location for them to be able to store
their code it enables them to stay
updated on the recent changes to the
repository because they'll be able to
pull the latest changes from that remote
repository so that they are ensuring
that as developers are always working on
the latest code so you can pull any
changes that you have made your fork
remote repository to your local
repository the command to be able to do
that is written here and we'll go
through a demo of how to actually do
that commands in a little bit good news
is if there are no changes you'll get a
notification saying that you're already
up to date and if there is a change it
will merge those changes to your local
repository and you get a list of the
changes that have been made remotely so
let's step through some of the commands
that we have in get so kit and it
initializes a local git repository on
your hard drive get add adds one or more
files to your staging area get commits -
M commit message is a commit changes via
git command commits changes to head up
to the git command commits changes to
your local staging area get status
checks the status of your current
repository and lists the files you have
changed get block provides a list of all
the commits made on your current branch
get diff user changes that you've made
to the file so you can achieve have
files next to each other you can
actually see the differences between the
two files I get push origin branch name
so the name of your branch command will
push the branch to the remote repository
so that others can use it this is what
you do at the end of your project get
config - global username will tell get
who you are by configuring the author
name and we'll go through that in a
moment
get config global user email will tell
git the author of by the email ID get
cloned creates a git repository copied
from a remote source get remote add
origin server connects the local
repository to the remote server and adds
the server to be able to push to it get
branch and then the branch name we'll
create a new branch for you to create a
new feature that you may be working on
get checkout and then the branch name
will allow you to switch from one branch
to another branch get merge branch name
will merge a branch into the active
branch so if you're working on a new
feature you can emerge that into the
main branch a git rebase will reapply
commits on top on another base tip and
get rebates will reapply commits on top
of another base tip and these are just
some of the popular git commands there
are some more but you can certainly dig
into those as you're working through
using git so let's go ahead and run a
demo using get so now we are going to do
a demo using gate on our local machine
and github as the remote repository for
this to work I'm going to be using a
couple of tools first I'll have the deck
open as we've been using up to this
point the second is I'm gonna have my
terminal window also available and let
me bring that over so you can just see
this and the terminal window is actually
running git bash as the software in the
background which you'll need to download
and install in order to run git bash
locally on your Windows computer as well
and in addition I'll also have the
github repository that we using for
simply learn already set up and ready to
go alright so let's get started so the
first thing we want to do is create a
local repository so let's go ahead and
do exactly that so the local repository
is going to reside in my development
folder that I have on my local computer
and for me to be able to do that I need
to create a drive in that folder so I'm
going to go ahead and change the
directory so I'm actually going to be in
that folder before I actually create to
make the new folder so I'm going to go
ahead and change directory and now I'm
in the development directory I'm going
to go ahead create a new folder and
that's gone ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
I'm going to move my cursor so that
emoji in the hello world folder and now
that I'm in the hello world folder I can
now initialize this folder as a git
repository and we'll use the git command
in it to initialize and let's go ahead
and initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here I have my hello
wall folder that I've created and you'll
now see that we have a hidden folder in
there which is called dot git and we
expand that we can actually see all of
the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so that we
can see the rest of the work and now if
we check on our folder here we actually
see this is users Mathew development
HelloWorld dot git and that matches up
with hidden folder here so we're going
to go ahead and create a file called
readme.txt in our folder so here is our
hello world folder and I'm going to go
ahead and using my text editor which
happens to be sublime I'm going to
create a file and it's gonna have in
there text hello world and I'm gonna
call this one readme dot txt but I go to
my hello world folder you'll see that we
have the readme.txt file actually in the
folder what's interesting is if I select
the git status command what it'll
actually show me is that this file has
not yet been added to the commits yet
for this project so even though the file
is actually in the folder it doesn't
mean that it's actually part of the
project for us to do that we actually
have to go and select
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the git status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the git status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders have been committed
and what we can now do is we can go and
actually add the readme file so let's go
ahead wisk insec at git add so the git
command is add readme dot txt
so that then adds that file into our
main project and we want to thank commit
those files into the main repositories
history and so to that do that we'll
have the the get command commit and
we'll do a message in that commit and
this one will be first commit and it has
committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and I can change this so we
can go hello get git is a very popular
version control solution and we'll we'll
save that now what we can do is we can
actually go and see if we have made
differences to the readme text so to do
that we'll use the diff command forget
so we do git diff and it gives us two
releases the first is what the original
text was which is hello world and then
what we have afterwards is what is now
the new text in green which is replace
the original text so what we can do now
is you want to go ahead and create an
account on github we already have one
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to match the account from
github with our local account so to do
that we're gonna go ahead and say gate
config and we're going to do - and it's
going to be a global user dot name and
we put in our user name that we use for
github and this instance we're using the
simply learn - github account name and
under the github account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
and this is as we called the repository
hello - world and what we want to do is
connect the local github account with
the remote hello world dot git account
and we do that by using this command
from get which is our remote connection
and so let's go ahead and type that in
open this up so we can see the whole
thing so we can type in git remote add
origin HTTP backslash backslash
github.com slash simply learn - github
and you have to get this type
incorrectly when you're typing in the
location hello - world dot get that
creates the connection to your hello
world account and now we want to do is
we want to push the files to the remote
location using the git push command
commit get push origin master so we're
going
had and connect to a local remote github
so I'm just going to bring up my
terminal window again and so that's like
git remote add origin and we'll connect
to the remote location github.com /
simply learn - github / hello - world
dot git
oh we actually have already connected so
we're connected to that successfully and
now we're going to push the master gish
so get push origin master and everything
is connected and successful and if we go
out to github now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago so what
can actually do now is we can go and
fork a project from github and clone it
locally so we're going to use this fork
tool that's actually available on github
let me show you where that is located
and here is our branching torse actually
changed more recently with a new UI
interface and once the complete we'll be
able to then pull a copy of that to our
accounts using the forks new HTTP URL
address so let's go ahead and do that
you
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
four options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now I'm
actually logged in with the default
primary count for this project so I
can't actually for the project as I'm
working on the main branch however if I
come in with a separate idea Here I am I
have a different ID and so I'm actually
pretending I'm somebody else I can
actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork and there we
are we have gone ahead and created the
fork so you want to say clone or
download with this and so this is the
isolate that you give me the web address
I can let me show you what that looks
like I'll open up my text editor just
that's the correct
I guess that is correct so I'm gonna
copy that and I can fork the project
locally and clone it locally I can
change the directory so I can create a
new directory that I'm gonna put my
files in and then post in that content
into that folder so I can now actually
have multiple versions of the same code
running on my computer I can then go
into the forked content and use the
patchwork command to edgy so I can
create a copy of that code that we've
just created from the college that's a
clone and we can create a new folder
that we're actually putting the work in
and we could for whatever reason we
wants to we call this where for a
patchwork and that would be maybe new
feature and then we can then paste in
the URL of the new directory though it
has the forked work in it and now at
this point we've now pulled in and
created a clone of the original content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then divert
our work separately so now what we can
actually do is we can actually create a
branch of the fork that we've actually
pulled in onto our computer so we can
actually then create our own code that
runs in that separate branch and so we
want to check out I'm the the branch and
then push the origin branch down to our
computer this will give us the
opportunities then add our collaborators
so we can actually then go over to
github and we can actually come in and
add in our collaborators
we will do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
github name or by email address or by
their full name one of the things that
you want to be able to do is ensure that
you're always keeping the code that
you're working on fully up-to-date by
pulling in all the changes from your
collaborators you can create a new
branch and then make changes emerged
into the master branch ID to do that you
would create a folder and then that
folder in this instance would be called
test we would then move our cursor into
the folder called test and then
initialize that folder so let's go ahead
and do that so that's cool create a new
folder and we're going to first of all
change our root folder and we're going
to go to development and I'm going to
create a new folder I call it test and
we're going to move into the test folder
and we will initialize that folder and
we're going to move some files into that
test folder
cause one test one and then we're gonna
do a file save as this one's going to be
test two and now we're going to commit
those files add kit add and then we'll
use the dot to pull in all files and
then git commit dash em hey Charlie in
the right folder here and I think I was
and now that I'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and and commit and it's
gone ahead and edit those files and so
we can see the two files that were
created I've been added into the master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
branch you call this one git branch test
under school branch and let's go ahead
create a third file to go into that
folder this is file three to file save
as we'll call this one test three text
and we'll go ahead and add that file and
to get add test three dot txt and we're
going to move from the master branch to
the test ground branch get check out
test underscore branch I switched to the
test branch and we be able to list out
all of the files that are in the teton
that branch now and we want to go
through and merge the files into one
area so let's go ahead and we'll do the
git merge test underscore branch as well
we've already updated everything so
that's good so otherwise it would tell
us what we would be merging and now all
the files are merged successfully into
the master branch there we go
Oh merge together fantastic and so what
we're going to do now is move from
master branch to test branch so git
checkout test underscore proj and
can modify the files the test3 file that
we took out and pull that file up and we
can now what if find and we can then
commit that file back in now we've
actually been out so then commit the
file with one changes and obviously it's
the text we change that was made now we
can now go through a process of checking
the file back in switching back to the
master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly we may
at one point want to rebase all the work
is kind of a hard thing you want to do
but it will allow you to allow for
managing for changes in the future
so let's switch to it back to our test
branch which I think we're actually on
we're going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's
copy those and that's created we'll
rename those tests four and five and so
we now have additional files and we're
going to add those into our branch that
we're working on so we're gonna go in
state git add dash a and we're gonna
commit those files git commit dash a
dash M adding two new files
and it's added in the two new files so
we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch and we
will switch them to our master branch we
want to rebase the master so we do git
rebase master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date we can go get checkout master to
switch to the master account that's
where I was till then continue through
and rebase the test branch and then list
all the files that are all in the same
area so let's go get rebase test
underscore branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly so
what we've learned in this class is
you've gone through and understand the
different version control systems out
there that a new advanced versioning
control system is distributed version
control system the most popular solution
for that is get and how git is different
to other services such as github or
gitlab and we've gone through all the
different commands that you can use from
when working with gates finally we
worked on a demo that allowed you to see
all the different tasks you can complete
with git
thank you for joining us on this
training session hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here